Speaker 1: I'm going to play a video for you
today that I know many of you will think has
to be fake. It has to be a comedy skit. It has
to be satire. It must be from Saturday Night
Live and it's not. I am going to play a clip
for you today of a mom interviewed on Fox News
who is suing, suing her son's school because
her son will no longer do chores at home
because he's been taught critical race
theory. Apparently, her son is half black.
She says in a New York Post article that her son
looks Hawaiian. And she says all of a sudden,
because of critical stuff that her son has been
taught, he won't do chores around the house
anymore. It is unbelievable. Look at this.
Speaker 2: All right. So, Melissa, you're
your son. Is the father's black? You're white. And
he never mentioned issues with race before. You're
saying what exactly changed?
Speaker 3:
Right. We didn't have issues before. He's in
eighth grade. They introduced this critical
program and they.
Speaker 1: Introduced the critical program. And
all of a sudden, what happened? Listen to this.
Speaker 3: And now he's having
racial issues that wasn't there before.
Speaker 2: What kind of racial issues is
he having?
Speaker 3:
Well, he's seen himself just as a black man.
He's seen things that don't go his way as racism.
And he's finding safety in numbers now.
Speaker 1: So he's finding safety in
numbers. I would love to explore that more.
Speaker 2: You're saying he gets a bad grade
at school? He blames racism or a girl rejects
him on a date? Racism. Are those the kind of
things you're seeing?
Speaker 3:
Yes. I asked them to clean the house. Racism? Yes.
Speaker 2: You're kidding, right? Are you serious?
Speaker 3: No, I'm serious. They have
totally changed his perspective. They have?
Speaker 1: Can you imagine? Hey, you're supposed
to vacuum. That's racist. Mom. Hey, I'm your mom.
It's time to vacuum. I mean, it's. You're
suing the school because it's. I can't get.
How is this a real segment? It's very
difficult to believe that this isn't a plan.
I actually thought this is going to be another
one. You know, when these people prank Fox News
and it turns out that it's actually a complete
and total joke, like there was this famous one.
We interviewed the guy, Max Rice, who went on Fox
and he pretended that he was a former Obama voter
who didn't who wanted to vote for Romney instead
because of some, he lost a bet. It was like this
whole fake thing and later it came out. It
was all a joke. I wrongly assumed this was
going to be a joke. And the there's one other
one possibility is the mom has completely lost
control of just parenting like she doesn't know
how to parent. That's one possibility. The other
possibility is that this is sort of like made
up or exaggerated. And she's using her kid as
a political pawn. Like at some point, don't you
say, listen, you've just got to do your homework.
You've just got to do your chores. I'm I'm the
parent. I'm in charge here. And she goes on
an international news outlet, which I can't
imagine is going to make circumstances that
much better for her kid in school as well. That
it just strikes me that that's not going to be a
particularly useful thing. And then again, in this
New York Post article that was written about this,
you know, New York Post, it's not a source
we typically use, but that's where she was.
She was interviewed. Virginia's school. Virginia
schools. Anti-Racist program has changed, my son,
Mom says. And she did say he looks Hawaiian.
He's beautiful. He didn't used to see himself
as different from other kids. Sure, his skin
tone was a little darker. His dad is black
and right. I guess the mom is white and Native
American, but she never wanted to box him in
with stifling racial classifications. And now an
anti-racist curriculum, she says, is itself racist
because it indoctrinate students and teachers in
a racial essentialist worldview. This is really
wacky stuff. If it wasn't so sad and dangerous
and disheartening, it would be funny because
it seems like comedy, but it's not. And I would
expect a lot more of this over the next few years.